these drones are designed to
revolutionize the fight against global
warming they're called seed dropping
drones and they can plant up to 40 000
trees a day
they fly above remote and rugged fields
that are often difficult to reach firing
seed pods onto the ground and leaving
the rest to nature
so whilst we are planting different
types of vegetation that could be trees
that could be shrubs that could be
grasses
what we're doing is rebuilding that
ecosystem that can support healthy soils
microbial communities wildlife
the drone was designed by an australian
biotech company the team is hoping to
plant a hundred million trees in two
years
eventually that will provide amazing
ecosystem services to humans and animals
and and the whole globe so that includes
pollination
um clean water clean air and
carbon sequestration
here seeds are isolated and match with a
perfect blend
each pod is created to thrive in the
environment it's expected to grow in
while the drone relies on artificial
intelligence the often tedious work that
leads to that innovation starts here
it's not a solution to global warming
the solution is not to emit the co2
but it does help the global
warming problem by removing co2 from the
atmosphere and usually creating a
cooling impact over the regions where
you've grown the forests
air seed has already planted more than
50 000 trees in australia and south
africa
next year is planning to extend its
reach to other parts of africa southeast
asia north america and europe
katie lopez
al jazeera